l'impression qu'au fil des années vous
êtes un peu truqueurs ise vous aimez
tout le monde
tout le monde est sympa tout le monde
est votre ami votre frère j'en fais
partie mais ça c'est vrai donc ne me
décevez pas dit la vérité
jimmy boisvert qui est là qui vient
d'arriver depuis hier je fais partie des
kiwis s'appelle jimmy mode et s'aplatit
mais omar aident ils à ap ap washington
ap à marrakech rsa et je vous la
donnerais hamburgers et makrouds dit
mohammed vous avez gagné hier vous êtes
le champion d'ailleurs vous allez
remettre votre titre en jeu dans un
instant vous savez que le champion peut
poser la question à qui il veut vous
avez une question veut poser apparemment
aujourd'hui une question qui attendait
tous les fans de tpm paie tous les
téléspectateurs et d'ailleurs sur
twitter hier ça fait couler beaucoup
d'encre on attend cette question grill
j'ai gagné beaucoup de choses hier le
respect des français le droit de vous
poser cette question
mais attention je vous connais mal en
tôle où je veux la vérité les yeux dans
les yeux pers tu as parlé j'ai parlé et
deux jours au bout de deux jours le
reste est normal de cette émission m'a
dit mon voisin mon frère donc pas de
pitié pitié pas de langue de bois parce
que j'ai l'impression qu'au fil des
années vous êtes un peu truck series et
vous aimez tout le monde
tout le monde est sympa tout le monde
est votre ami votre frère j'en fais
partie mais c'est vrai donc ne me
décevez pas dit la vérité
parmi tous les invités que vous avez
reçus s'il fallait me donner le top 3 de
ce que vous avez détesté
oh là là j'adore déjà alors se mouiller
mais d'ailleurs me tourner vers touba
d'abord que dans la bible aux seuls amis
proches antoine latham silence à moi
aussi
voilà thomas tour et répondez à cette
question toi dans ta situation c'est
très délicat
c'est vrai c'est très délicat moi je
penses que tu peux laisser des indices
mais pas dire alors je vais laisser des
indices hantait enquête exclusive
bernard bernard de la villardière tu as
eu peu de surprises non parce qu'on se
le dise permane david à redire c'est mon
choix avait demandé trois noms bernard
de la villardière ensuite eu alors
tellement pizza et ça je monsieur des
pizzas ce qui dit le monsieur des pizzas
jamais reçu de pizzaïolo ici trop facile
mais ça y est ça y est plus acérées
c'est un accord à l'amiable s'arrange
rouge avec deux stars ça change
alors non je vais dire christophe
beaugrand mois boys se vide laissé des
indices
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en fait les jeux atari et michel cymes
c'est bon ça c'est très cher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]